the breach of the Nova kakov kadam is
being called Europe's largest man-made
environmental disaster in decades and
Ukrainian officials lost no time in
calling it a terrorist act and an
international War crime
the unleashing of the torrent of water
from the huge Reservoir swallowed up
whole streets dozens and dozens of
villages and parts of hairson City
within hours
residents scrambled to safety with their
pets just picking up what they need
whilst neighbors and relatives hastily
set out to find stranded elderly family
members who can't Wade through these
Rising Waters
and others watch from their Windows as
the water just Rose and Rose
I don't know what to do lidmiller says
how can they do that okay it's War
soldiers are fighting each other but to
blow up the hydroelectric Dam I can't
find the words it's Barb Barrack
the water is really Rising quite rapidly
does it give you an idea of how deep it
is this is one of the the plant pots and
we're in one of the main streets
of hairson city and even whilst we've
been here it's risen a couple of inches
I'd say
the people of hairson City have been
occupied and they're regularly bombed
and shelled so being deliberately
flooded isn't phasing them when you live
here for more than six months after
being bombed all the time after being
scared all the time so it's scary but
not so much as you're bombed all the
time
so we're trying to stay safe the
president called an emergency meeting of
his Security Council and left his East
European Partners in no doubt who he
thought was to blame
um
[Music]
the dam Blast has wreaked havoc on both
sides of the dinipro river including the
Russian control territory on the
Southeast Bank plunging vast areas on
that side underwater too Russian
officials have denied their responsible
claiming the Ukrainian sabotaged the dam
because of their failing
counter-offensive Association
that's not how they see it
normal people will never do that he says
about the dam blast they're just
terrorists
what can you call this she tells us it's
genocide of the nation
misery again for the civilians but the
floods will also likely tie up Emergency
Services as well as impede the Ukrainian
forces and their plans for a
counter-offensive Alex Crawford Sky News
in Pearson City